hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game that just happened in the pro
chest league I decided to show it right
away as it deserves to be showed right
away it's India 65th - Grandmaster
Raunak Silvani I don't know if he's
still the youngest Grandmaster from
India India is producing grandmasters at
an alarming rate but he was so I don't
know if he's still the youngest at 14
years of age faces a shocker momma Dee
are of who of course needs no
introduction
well that being said let's check out the
game so without further ado roundup
opens with E 4 we have c6 mama dr who
goes for the caro-kann defense Knight to
c3
we have d5 striking in the center Knight
f3 and Bishop to g4 now now we have h3
asking black to decide whether to go
back with the bishop or to give up the
bishop pair we have captures Queen
captures and now p6 closing the cage
after the light square Bishop has been
disposed off and here D for a well known
pawn sacrifice by white in this line be
captures on e4 Knight characters and
Queen characters on d4 grabbing the d4
pawn and here the the the most played
move is a Bishop to d3 here but sadani
goes for Bishop to g5 and it's really
it's not a new move but it's only been
played a few times already threatening
some very nasty areas like rugby one
attack the Queen Queen moves and rugby
eight mate so you have to do something
about that and the best in this position
is Knight to d7 90 d7 there is one game
where this was played in black was able
to win the game because you eliminate
all the threats then you were gonna go
Bishop e7 Knight of 6 and so on continue
continue developing and hopefully when
they enjoy your extra phone but here
mama DRF after Bishop to g5 played f6
now f6 is a new move so already as of
move 8 we have a completely new game and
this is something that happens quite
often even if you're a well former
member of the 2800 club like mom you're
up here you sometimes think that you can
play a move like that and they get away
with it
so here rook to d1 continuing like
nothing happened the queen is under
attack
and now Queen captures unbe to grabbing
yet another pawn the bishop on g5 is
still under attack so Bishop back to c1
and now not wanting to grab more
material
mummy-ji our brings the Queen back into
the defense and Savannah continues his
development Bishop to e2 so it's kind of
problematic for black to continue
development you you have to first clear
the bishop and the night if you're gonna
Castle kingside
or if we're gonna Castle queenside you
still have to get rid of this night so
Knight to d7 and here
Silvana castles Mari are off also
castles and now it seems like you're
grab two pawns he's safely castle and
he's now gonna continue developing his
pieces but not all is as it seems Bishop
to f4 in this move will prevent the
black King from from looking at some
safer squares so he's gonna be pretty
much stuck here with this diagonal being
closed with Queen back to a5 and the now
comes Queen to b3 again with some very
nasty ideas for example if black isn't
careful let's say you develop a knight
you already get a night check King moves
and Queen captures on b7 mate so you
have to be be very careful so we have e
5 blocking this diagonal so now the King
can move and but here comes another
brilliant move by Silvani Bishop to g4
preparing more fees opera opera game
maneuver which is the to give up the
rook and then bring the other rook over
to d1 also sacrifices the bishop on f4
really really amazing stuff we've eek a
present f4 but there doesn't seem to be
a better move so captures on e4 on f4 we
have rook captures on d7 rook captures
on d7 and now rook to d1 again attacking
the pin piece and now it's again very
hard to decide what to do here I you
can't really go after the rook here so
f5 was played by Mohammed ER of the
queen guards DF 5 square so it does make
sense also it frees DF 6 square for the
knight there was also the tricky line
Knights to h6 but then white can just
add another attacker and after let's say
Bishop d3 now this rook controls the the
back rank now you have to give back some
material Queen captures on d7 King to b8
and you get this position where
we're you a white will grab on g7 and
well all-in-all is gonna be better for
white but extremely complicated so this
was one of the ways for for Mama drf to
go but we have f5 here and okay the best
room no longer attacks the rook but now
comes Quinta East six and now adding
another attacker to the rook and not
caring about the bishop and the point is
if you capture the bishop it's it's game
over Queen captures King b8 Queen e8
check King goes here and then Queen
Queen to d8 will be checkmate so after
Queen to e6 we have Queen to d8 adding
well another defender to the rook but
now just Bishop captures on f5 now you
can just eliminate and once again you
add a third attacker to the rook on d7
we have Queen to e7 hoping to trade a
trade away the Queen's but now Queen
back to b3 keeping Queens in the game
Queen back to be four again offering a
queen trade but now Queen f7 and here
mom Jarvis in trouble because trying to
repeat with Queen to e7 is just met with
Bishop characters on d7 with check and
now the King hunt begins King c7 Queen
to f4 with check king b6 rook to be one
with check King to a6 now a very sneaky
night the c5 Czech Queen captures on c5
and the Queen to a4 check Queen blocks
on a5 and now even feel free to pause
the video in this position that never
happened because it's a beautiful mate
in three so feel free to pause and find
this beautiful mate well I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on finding it it's it's a position you
want to remember and it made you want to
remember and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show its Queen
captures on c6
this comes with check the King has no
squares so you can either capture and
the dis runs into Bishop to c8 mate
because the row covers at the entire B
file enter the Queen prevents the King
from going to a5 or after Queen captures
on c6 you can play b6 but then still
better up the c8 is made or you can
block with the Queen and then just
captures captures and the Queen to a4 is
mate so this is a the danger that lurks
after Queen to f7 if you try and repeat
so Mohammad yafa goes in Knights to e7
now the Queen no longer attacks the
but now it's time to capture real
characters on d7 now threatening some
very nasty discoveries also just our
queen to eat mate it is in the position
so King to be eight now you will be able
to employ with the night but it doesn't
matter Queen e8 check Knight to c8 and
now rook to b8 again a triple attack on
the c8 square Mahmud RF can easily
resign here but he creates some room for
the King still we have characters King
to a7 and now at to put the finishing
touch Queen to b8 taking away the square
from the from the black king and next
move whatever black plays rook to e8
will be made well okay you could prolong
with Queen b1 checking h2 but then there
are no more useful checks so rook to e8
will be made so really really impressive
stuff
the this Bishop to g4 maneuver really
reminded me after this 'if I've the
Bishop to g4 really reminded me of
Morpheus Opera House game so I decided
to name it in something like that still
haven't decided what I'm going to call
it but it will include the Opera House
as it was just amazing Murphy Murphy
created his opera game at the age of 21
I believe in 1958 and around Silvani
well okay this is a rapid online game
from the protest League but still III do
I really enjoyed it and I'm very sure
you you have as well and he created his
one at the age of 14 so we'll see we
will see what else happens but yeah
that's the game like I said after this
Queen to d8 move mom resigned and a
brilliant victory for a young around
oxyde Bonnie that's the game I would
like to thank Johannes broad wall
Patrick Bogota Kenneth wise Joseph
sarkodie and David arrived for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Praxis festival checking up on the
protest league continuing the Paul
Morphy saga and of course checking up on
your wonderful suggestions so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day